Hallo?
Hallo, hallo?
Also die Sache heute war echt stressig, ne?
Ich bin heimgekommen,
hab was aufgenommen,
hab das gerendert,
hab's hochgeladen,
hab was gegessen,
hab festgestellt,
ich hab übelst beeilt mit Futtern,
ich wollte eigentlich schon vor einer halben Stunde online sein,
hab ich festgestellt,
was ich aufgenommen hab, sackt,
hat mir nicht gefallen,
gelöscht,
schon mal neu aufgenommen,
hochgeladen,
hab ich die zweite Hälfte gegessen,
hab das Video freigeschaltet,
hab den Streamtitel geändert,
hab die Videotags angepasst und die Playlists,
das Video freigeschaltet
und hab den Stream angeschaltet.
So sieht's aus.
So, habt ihr das Video heute schon gesehen?
Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Sell out.
Was war denn da dran jetzt?
Ach, ist es der 500?
Oh, ist das der 500. Win?
Oh.
Moment, ist das...
Leute, hab ich mich vertan?
Ist das der 500. Win?
Hab ich das sogar falsch,
falsch gedeutet?
Wählen Sie das Spiel
100 Mal in frei für alle
mit den meisten Punkten?
Sind das gar nicht 100 Wins,
sind das 500 Wins?
Ha?
Da muss ich mal meinen Streamtitel editieren,
würde ich sagen.
Äh, mal Videotitel.
Okay.
Big Brain, würde ich mal sagen.
Huge Brain.
Muss ich sagen.
Massive.
Enormous Brain.
Mein Browser hängt.
Okay.
Dann editieren wir mal den Titel.
Das ist schief und heißt MVP.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, okay, okay.
MVP Black Ops 1. Gucken wir mal.
Was wird heute gemacht?
Es ist die Apple Keynote angeguckt.
Okay.
MVP.
Free for all.
Ne.
Siehste?
Der Typ hat keine Ahnung,
der das in die Comments schreibt.
Also hatte ich doch Big Brain.
Und der Kerl hat keine Ahnung.
Also alles richtig gemacht, Max.
Easy.
Ja, Leute.
Habt ihr das Video heute schon geguckt?
Wir haben jetzt noch Zeit.
Wir haben noch 20 Minuten Zeit.
Und ich muss mal kurz auf Klo,
weil ich noch nicht...
Ich will weder kacken,
noch...
Oh.
Wow.
Wunderbar.
Intro.
Was nannt der Typ?
Ja, derией.
Der mein Damn, ich ja die.
Hey, meg cookies.
טَّ.
O-o-o-h.
Ja genau.
Boah, boah.
Wie solls das werden?
Vervensci.
Genau, äh,؟
Ja, und welches?
Ey, die Putperaut・・・
Du mit echtem Mustern.
Sag mal, ist das zu gwa-
kur all, oder...
Huuh.
Ja, was ist das wieder für komische Musik?
So Leute, also, ich muss jetzt nochmal aufs Klo.
Ich mache euch jetzt mal ein aktuelles Video an, für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben.
Und jetzt gehe ich mal kurz pinkeln.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max und heute habe ich mal ein ganz besonderes Gameplay für euch, nämlich meinen 100. Black Ops 1 Free For All Win.
Damit hätte ich ehrlich gesagt selber nicht mehr gerechnet im Jahr 2019.
Ich darf nicht vergessen, das Game ist glaube 7 oder 8 Jahre alt, also uralt.
Und ungefähr genauso lange habe ich das Game auch nicht mehr gespielt.
Das heißt, das kam total random.
Ich habe auf einmal den Erfolg am Ende gekriegt und habe mir gedacht, weißt du was Max, das Gameplay nimmst du, weil ich finde, es ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich habe ein paar Stunden gespielt, ich bin auch mit der Zeit immer wieder besser reingekommen.
Score ist ganz ansehnlich, Killstreaks haben ordentlich reingebasht.
Außerdem ist es der 100. Black Ops 1 Free For All Win.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ein paar Stunden gespielt.
Und ich habe dementsprechend auch einige halbwegs brauchbare Gameplays erspielt.
Ein paar richtig nice Gameplays, auch mit nicht so den alltäglichen Waffen.
Und mich würde das mal interessieren, wollt ihr die Gameplays überhaupt noch sehen?
Ich meine, das ist 2019, Modern Warfare ist demnächst am Start.
Vielleicht sagt ihr, ey Alter, Max, wie ein junger Black Ops 1 Gameplay ist.
Ich habe das vor allem auch gespielt, dass ich mich ein bisschen besser auf Konsole in Call of Duty reinfinden kann.
Weil die Modern Warfare Alpha startet auf der Konsole.
Gut, das ist Xbox.
Startet auf der PS4.
Aber ein bisschen mehr Konsole spielen, zack, Panic Knife.
Kann ja nichts schaden.
Aber ich glaube, das war gar kein Panic Knife.
Ich glaube, das war ein, wie nennt man das?
Ein Absichtsknife.
Genau, also wenn ihr die Gameplays sehen wollt, schreibt mir das Ganze mal in die Kommentare rein.
Und denkt natürlich auch an den 80 FPS Abo-Flatrate.
Auch garantiert kostenlos, no scam, garantiert.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, als ich wieder ein paar Runden Black Ops 1 gespielt habe.
Oder, da muss ich ein bisschen anders anfangen.
Was mir jetzt auch schon aufgefallen ist, die ich da längere Zeit mal wieder gespielt habe.
Ich habe ja auch letztens mal wieder ein bisschen Overwatch, äh, Role Queue und so ausprobiert.
Es gibt Sachen, die verlernt man einfach nicht.
Ähm, klar, man suckt, wenn man einloggt nach 7 Jahren.
Keine Frage, man kann ja auch nicht erwarten, dass man in ein Spiel wieder einloggt nach 7 Jahren und direkt abgeht und owned.
Ich glaube, das werden die wenigsten haben.
Aber es gibt so gewisse Sachen, wenn man, wenn man ein Spiel hardcore gegrindet hat.
Und ich würde mal sagen, das geht so ab 100 Stunden los.
Eher, eher bis 1000 Stunden, ja.
Oder, oder noch mehr.
Wenn man ein Spiel hardcore gegrindet hat, es gibt Sachen, die verlernt man einfach nicht.
Man hat die Maps im Hinterkopf, man hat die Game Mechanics irgendwie noch im Hinterkopf.
Ich kann euch heute noch sagen, so die besten Waffen, Perks, sonst was Kombinationen.
Nicht, dass ich die jetzt unbedingt gespielt hätte.
Wobei, die Galil mit Silencer übertrieben, äh, übertrieben nice Waffe gewesen ist.
Ähm, auch in MP2 kriege ich die ganzen Sachen noch zusammen.
Overwatch kriege ich auch noch fast alles zusammen.
Also alle Spiele, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, die man hardcore gegrindet hat, man verlernt sie nicht so richtig.
Aber es ist eher so ein bisschen damit zu vergleichen, wenn man nach, nach Jahren teilweise wieder anfängt zu spielen.
Es ist eher so ein bisschen damit zu vergleichen, wie wenn man, äh, im Urlaub gewesen ist, ja.
Und in der ganzen Zeit keinen Controller oder keine Tastatur in der Hand hatte.
Und sich dann nach 14 Tagen oder 3 Wochen wieder einen Rechner setzt oder, oder Controller vor die Konsole setzt, Controller in die Hand nimmt.
Dann, dann denkt man immer erstmal so, Alter, hm, das fühlt sich jetzt einfach ein bisschen komisch an.
Und genau so ist es da auch.
Du fängst das Spiel wieder an und du kennst es in deinem Kopf eigentlich noch.
Aber, aber dir fehlen letztendlich so die Feinheiten, ja.
Dir fehlt ein bisschen die Reaktion, dir fehlt ein bisschen das, das, ähm, die Keybindings, welchen Knopf du jetzt drücken musst, ja.
Dir fehlt ein bisschen so im Winkel, wie du die Granaten werfen musst und sowas.
Aber im Kopf hat man das Game immer noch drinne.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das Gefühl kennt, bei Games, die ihr wirklich lange gegrindet habt, ja.
Bei, bei, bei Dark, Dark Edge of Camelot, das ist das erste MMORPG, was ich gespielt habe, tausende Stunden lang.
Kann ich euch heute noch die besten Spots, die besten Skills, die besten, äh, äh, Spells und,
alles erzählen.
Überhaupt kein Problem.
Einfach Hardcore gegrindet und irgendwie verliert man es nicht.
Und so ist es, so war es, vom Gefühl her war es in Black Ops 1 auch so.
Übrigens, Black Ops 1, finde ich, hat, ähm, von allen Call of Duties, da ist er nämlich, der Blackbird, ähm, von allen Call of Duties, die ich aktiv gespielt habe,
wie gesagt, die letzten paar habe ich ja nicht mehr so Hardcore, Hardcore durch, durch gegrindet.
Von allen Call of Duties, die ich gespielt habe bisher, finde ich, wisst ihr jetzt Bescheid, ist der Blackbird, auch so im Nachhinein, ich hab mir da so ein bisschen Gedanken drüber gemacht,
der Blackbird ist der beste Killstreak.
Vielleicht ähnlich geil wie in den AC-130 oder den Chopper Gunner in MW2, aber ich finde, der Blackbird passt zur Hunde am Start, zack, jetzt, äh, kriegen sie, kriegen sie auf den Sack.
Der Blackbird ist einfach ein nicer Killstreak, einfach weil er, weil er dazu anregt, dass man auch aktiv weiterspielen muss und weil er ordentlich platziert ist.
Er ist mit sieben Kills jetzt nicht, oder mit Hardline in dem Fall, ja, nicht so extrem hoch, dass man ihn, dass man ihn irgendwie nicht kriegen kann.
Und wenn man ihn kriegt, muss man aktiv weiterspielen und nicht, und nicht irgendwie in der Ecke schimmeln, so wie, so wie der Typ, den hätte ich übrigens auf dem Blackbird sehen können.
Und die nächsten Killstreaks sind damit dann relativ einfach erreichbar, wenn man das halt ausnutzt.
Und das, das finde ich cool.
So einen Killstreak brauchst, finde ich, hoffe ich mal, im, im, im neuen Call of Duty auch.
Ich hab mir die Killstreaks noch nicht angeguckt, ich lass mich da mal überraschen.
Und das finde ich einfach, finde ich einfach nice, ja.
Blackbird, beste.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das Ganze seht, würde mich mal interessieren.
Aber das ist der Killstreak.
So in allen Call of Duties, der gefällt mir eigentlich mit Abstand am besten.
So, Killcam, Hund am Start, zack, in your face.
Wie auch immer er das Ganze jetzt gemacht hat, man weiß es nicht so genau.
Zumindest jetzt gleich, zack, da ist der Erfolg.
Beenden Sie das Spiel 100 Mal, frei vor alle, mit den meisten Punkten.
Ich hätte damit selbst nicht gerechnet im Jahr 2019, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hoffe, euch hat das Video gefallen und an alle Apple-Fans, denkt heute Abend 19 Uhr an die Keynote.
Ich werde das Ganze übrigens Livestreamen, nochmal so angemerkt.
Wir machen an der Stelle Schluss.
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
See you.
Dann haben wir alles.
So, also Frage, gab es hier irgendeine Frage von Backstream, habe ich gelesen vorhin.
Ähm, wo ist es denn?
Er schreibt, moin Max, habe mich mittlerweile beworben.
Ach ja, ich erinnere mich, genau.
Bin durch die ersten beiden Bewerbungsphasen eine etwas größeren Elektro- und Automatisierungsunternehmen in meiner Umgebung durch.
Jetzt fehlt nur noch die letzte.
Bewerbungsgespräch und Gruppenaufgabe.
Also Gruppenaufgabe ist richtig reudig.
Was sie so einen Scheiß überhaupt noch machen.
Das sind dann solche komischen Dinger wie, lesen sie den Zettel zuerst durch.
Komplett.
Am Ende steht dann, ah, du musst überhaupt nichts machen, einfach abgeben.
Ähm, schreibst du dir eigentlich vor Videos immer auf, was du sagst?
In letzter Zeit schreibe ich mir tatsächlich, ich glaube das merkt man in den Videos auch, schreibe ich mir zumindest so ein bisschen was auf.
Weil, meine Videos früher waren schon ziemlich zusammenhanglos.
Ich mach, x-te-psy-co-lo-gio-kuss.
Twitch Prime, Pok.
Mal gucken, wie das neue iPhone wird, ja, da bin ich auch gespannt.
Also ich als Apple-Fan, ja.
Also, ihr wisst ja, ich hab alles Apple und ich hab Steve Jobs und Tim Cook überm Bett hängen.
Ich hab hier jetzt extra schon, neben mich, vor allem Tim Cook, hab ich überm, überm Bett hängen.
Ähm, ich hab überhaupt kein Bett, wo man was oben dran hat.
An der Decke hängen.
ähm, nein, Pfeiffer hast du nicht verpasst
ich hab jetzt alles hier am Start, ja
mein iPhone 6 ist am Start, mein iPhone
10 ist am Start, mein
iPad ist am Start, meine
Apple Watch ist am Start, mein
iPod ist am Start, meine
Earbuds-Dings sind am Start
meine, meine, ähm, was haben die
sonst noch, mein iMac ist am Start
ähm
mein MacBook ist am Start
alles am Start
so richtig so, so
Altarmäßig, ja
ja, Leute, ihr könnt übrigens heute mitspielen
und zwar, der Serious Max hat
ein Bullshit-Bingo programmiert
was für jeden ein bisschen anders
randomized wird, weiß nicht, ob er da ist
äh
Max Exe, dankeschön, Pock
Pfeiffer Review war noch nicht, ich hab auch noch
kein Custom-Rom auf dem Shield-Tablet, ne
ach, den Standfuß hab ich vergessen
stimmt, stimmt, der Standfuß, ja und jetzt
ernsthaft, also was ich wirklich
habe von Apple
ist ein iPhone 6, ein iPhone 10
und ein iPad, allerdings
ratet mal, was ich mir davon selbst
gekauft hab, Jan
Goe, Q
Jan Goku
ich weiß nicht, wie man es richtig ausnimmt, Twitch Prime, dankeschön
Prime, Samus
das iPad, genau, das iPad
hab ich mir selbst gekauft
weil, ich finde, Tablet-mäßig
gibt's Android
leider nicht so viel Gutes, ich hab
glaube, hier oder, warte mal
was hab ich denn, ich glaube, also ich hab noch jede Menge
Android-Tablets, aber ich finde, ich benutze am liebsten
bei den Tablets das, das, das iPad
reinzubenutzen
was sind die ROM-Komponenten
in einem PC?
weiß nicht, was du meinst
Amazon-Tablets, ja, ein Amazon-Tablet
also, ich hab
zwei HD10-Fire-Tablets
oh, es geht, es geht
im Steve Jobs-Center
ähm, der Eichler
Stufe 1, Pock
ähm
also, lass mal überlegen, was hab ich denn
ich hab Nvidia Shield-Tablet alt
Nvidia Shield-Tablet etwas neuer
mit gefixtem Akku
ähm, einfach mal 73.000
ähm, ich hab
nen Tegra Note 7
ich hab irgend so'n komisches Asus-Tablet
ich hab so'n olles Lenovo
ähm, Android-Tablet
ähm
die Fire HD10s hatte ich schon
ich glaub, das war's
und halt, also
ich hab noch das iPad dabei
also, ich hab wirklich
mehr als genug
ähm, ähm
Auswahl, ja
Tablets, und ich muss sagen
rein zum Benutzen her
ist das iPad das Beste
allerdings
in, haben halt die
Android-Sachen
nen riesigen Vorteil gegenüber Apple
du kannst damit halt was machen
was nicht
wenn was, irgendwas nicht standardmäßig so ist
kannst du's halt unter Android ändern
unter iOS hast du halt gelitten, ja
also, es hat, hat's, hat
vor allem was
im Heim-Automatisierungsbereich angeht
oder irgendwas, wo man bisschen was automatisch machen will
ist Android meilenweit vorne
einfach zu benutzen, find ich, das, äh, das iPad immer noch am schönsten
oh, hier, wir haben Subs
ähm, und zwar haben wir Chilora
Twitch Prime zwei Monate
und dann haben wir noch Astflex
zwei Monate
im zweiten Monat
aber ab nächsten Monat, Leute, brauch ich neue Sub-Patches
Sub-Patches
und jetzt haben wir noch From Future
Twitch Prime
oh, es, Apple, Apple, Apple-Musik geht los
Alter, was ist das?
Max, wenn der YouTube-Player anfängt zu spacken
dann switch auf die Apple-Seite
wir können auch gleich auf die Apple-Seite gehen
wie kann man die Auflösung ändern bei Apple?
Alter, die Musik, was ist das denn?
kann man hier keine Auflösung ändern bei Apple?
das ist nicht Design genug, oder was?
ja, also Leute, Bullshit-Bingo
wollte ich euch ja noch zeigen
wir gucken das mal auf YouTube
ähm
also Bullshit-Bingo, und zwar der Serious Max
unserer Mod, oder einer unserer Mods
hat eine Bullshit-Bingo gebastelt für die Präsentation
ich poste euch das Ganze mal
muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich das finde
das war irgendwie github.io
äh
ob ich das aus dem Kopf hinkriege
Serious Max
HTML5
Bullshit-Bingo
äh, fuck
ähm
ich muss mal kurz im Discord gucken, wie die richtige Adresse war
ach, da ist es doch, perfekt
ihr wisst das schon viel besser als ich
da haben wir es am Start
also, könnt ihr alle aufmachen
die Adresse
und wir refreshen jetzt einfach 10 mal
und gucken, was da so rauskommt
ja, es sind immer ein bisschen andere Sachen
so
und ihr gewinnt natürlich
wenn ihr sowas
hahaha
der Sound ist ja geil
also wir refreshen
jetzt noch ein paar mal
und dann haben wir hier was zum ausfüllen
ich muss jetzt noch meinen letzten Keks futtern schnell
so
ähm, gut
Keks weg
ähm, auch danke für die ganzen
Follows, die es gegeben hat in den letzten Tagen
aber, ich glaube
ich mach den
ich mach den Follow-Sound mal einen Ticken leiser
für den, für den Stream
ich muss gucken, wo das geht
hier, Alert-Box, Test-Follower
ah, ein bisschen laut
ähm
oder stört das nicht großartig, sagt mal
soll ich den Follow-Sound ein bisschen leiser oder
es passt so
ein bisschen leiser, ja gut, na
ok, ich mach, ich mach einen Ticken, einen Ticken leiser
ähm
Moment, wo ging das überhaupt noch
hier, Follow
so, Sound-Volume ist auf
8%, ich muss mir das mal aufschreiben
dass ich das in der Nachhinein wieder so einstellen kann
machen wir es jetzt mal ein bisschen leiser
machen wir es mal auf 4, weil wir
machen den Follow-Sound einfach komplett aus
machen den
Follow-Sound komplett aus und ich würde sagen
wir machen auch die Follow-Einblendung
mal aus
für die Dauer hier vom Stream
weil sonst ist das die ganze
Zeit hier im, im Beige, ne
Max, ich subscribe
wenn du den Namen vom neuen iPhone vorhersagst
das Ding muss ja eigentlich
iPhone 11 heißen, oder
ups
vielleicht machen sie aber auch die Microsoft
Taktik oder, oder die Battlefield
Taktik und nennen das einfach iPhone 1
Welche Vorteile hat
das normale Visual Studio im Gegensatz
zu Visual Studio Code, das sind beides
zwei komplett unterschiedliche Arten von
Software, das eine ist ein Text-Editor
mit Plugins
äh, das andere ist ne .NET und
C++ IDE
Visual Studio Code ist cool für Sachen
wenn du HTML und Javascript und sowas
machen willst, wenn du .NET programmieren willst
brauchst du Visual Studio, oder Rider oder sowas
zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe
die heißen halt nur Microsoft-typisch, aber
wieder sehr ähnlich, haben miteinander überhaupt gar nichts
zu tun, also entweder
heißt das Ding iPhone 1, iPhone 1
iPhone 2019, das wäre natürlich
nochmal absolut next level
Q-Chat, ahjaja
Q-Con ist am Start, Stufe 1
Monate am Stück
vielleicht
machen sie es auch umgedreht
und zählen jetzt wieder rückwärts
also jetzt kommt wieder iPhone 9 oder sowas
oder, oder, oh was richtig
next level ist
iPhone
X plus 1
oder USB
standardmäßig
iPhone X mal X
was haltet ihr denn davon
iPhone X mal X, das finde ich gut
das wird es sein
he he
mal gucken, wir lassen es mal auf uns zukommen
was da passiert, oh Leute hier, also denkt dran
ihr könnt alle mitspielen, Bullshit Bingo
ans unser Mod, äh Mod, das hier ist Max
hat das programmiert, einfach hier auf diese
Adresse gehen
da kriegt ihr eine randomized Version
und wer
als erstes
Bingo hat
gewinnt
dass er mich
Twitch Prime sammeln darf
bester oder
next level
wisst ihr
es gibt Noobs auf Twitch
die verschenken Subs
der, der eigentliche
High IQ Move ist
den Leuten zu erlauben
sich zusammen
das ist die eigentliche Sache
ja
und ihr wisst bei mir das das stimmt
weil der Chat musste mich circa
2 Jahre dazu drängen Partner zu machen
auf Twitch und jetzt wo ich Partner bin auf Twitch
will ich auch das Twitch Money haben
Chrome Effect
ist am Start
Postfrosch Twitch Prime
glaubst du die stellen ein neues iPhone vor
ich geh mal stark von aus
da geh ich schon mal von aus
das sie ein iPhone vorstellen
Melo Leaks Stufe 1
Huge
ein richtig echter Sub
kannst du die ganzen Emotes verwenden
die ganzen 4 Emotes die wir haben Leute
denkt dran alle die gesubt haben
wir haben 4 Emotes nicht vergessen
ich hab zwar 16 Emote Slots oder so
aber ich habe immerhin 4 Emotes
4 mal 4 ist 16
quick maths
nur 4
ja ich hab sie immer durchgebacken kriegen
neue Emotes ja ich weiß ich muss mich um neue Emotes kümmern
aber die wichtigsten haben wir schon mal
ich glaube das
welches Emote
könnte und sind immer übelst durch
organized
Leute
3 Minuten
eigentlich juckt es mich gar nicht wenn ich ehrlich bin
oh habe ich Subs übersehen
Sekunde
was ist mit der Musik bei Apple los
ups
ist das für Musik
na na na na na
Coldstar 12
iPhantom
alle beide am Start
Coldstar mit dem richtigen Sub
und Phantom auch mit dem richtigen
Prime Sub
sehr nice
wie funktioniert das Bingo Spiel ernsthaft
jetzt
ernsthaft
du klickst das einfach an
du kriegst das einfach
du klickst das an wenn die was sagen
also wenn jetzt ich erklär das jetzt einmal
ja ich glaube ja das ist Gbait aber ich erklär es trotzdem
also wenn die
jetzt irgendwas sagen im
Stream was hier drauf passt ja
äh nicht crowd nicht
excited nicht sagen ne Statistik komische
Kontaktnamen äh
neue Apple TV Screensaver nicht in
Deutschland Android Bashing Sport
wenn die das sagen kannst du es anklicken und wenn du
quasi hier einmal einmal wenn du horizontal
vertikal oder ähm
wie heißt es
diagonal
was hast dann ähm du kannst es übrigens so oft
refreshen wie du willst bis du was hast was dir gefällt
Link dafür ja ich paste es nochmal hier rein
...
Schau mal, vorherige Nachricht.
Oh.
Kann nicht vorherige Nachricht.
Chat ist zu viel drin.
Okay, gleich geht's los, Leute.
30 Sekunden.
Wir hatten ja letztens von Telekom Bullshit.
Morgen wird uns in Bonn
der neueste Streich vorgestellt.
Blockchain E-Scooter.
Das ist doch jetzt Verarschung, oder?
Leute, sind die zu spät?
Was ist da los?
Was ist bei Apple los?
Sind zu spät?
Wupp S?
Hm.
Okay.
Klapper, klapper.
Ich muss mal kurz checken, ob die Lautstärke passt.
Ja, ich denk schon.
Sagt mir mal, ob die Lautstärke passt.
Was ist da los?
Bisschen laut, oder?
Die Musik?
Was ist da los?
Oh, man kann das jetzt zumachen.
Alles die neuen Kameras.
Apple TV Plus.
Bei der Musik komm ich auch auf ganz andere Gedanken.
Da geb ich dir recht.
Oh, jetzt mit zwei Kameras.
Oder mit drei Kameras.
Mal schauen.
Ah, okay, eine Uhr.
Ein buntes iPhone.
Ganz viele bunte iPhones.
Bunte Stifte.
Wonderful.
Wonderful Tools.
Vor allem 1.000 Euro teure Monitorstiefel.
Sind ganz toll.
Auf den haben wir gewartet.
Erstmal an einem eskalieren.
Noch ein bisschen leiser.
We've always believed that by giving people wonderful tools, you enable them to do wonderful
things.
At Apple, we put the customer at the center of everything that we do.
With products and technologies that are designed in the service of humanity.
Natürlich.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Innovations, that enrich people's lives, to help them learn, create, work, play, share
and stay healthy.
Die wollen nur der Menschheit helfen.
Through the deep integration of hardware, software and services, these products empower
people to do incredible things every day.
Abgekürzt Hass.
We have a huge morning planned for you.
With some truly beautiful products.
mit wirklich großen Announcements.
Also werde ich...
Ja?
Ja!
Also werde ich meine normalen Updates
nicht mehr verpassen
und beginne direkt mit
der App Store.
Wir...
Wir geben eine ganz neue Art,
auf der App Store zu genießen,
mit Apple Arcade.
Wir haben mit den weltweit
innovativen Game-Developern
die Grenzen des Möglichen
zu drücken.
Um euch alles über Apple Arcade zu erzählen,
möchte ich Anne an die Bühne bringen.
Anne!
Wir freuen uns, Apple Arcade
auf der App Store zu eröffnen.
Der weltweit erste Spiel-Subscription
für Handy, Desktop und TV.
Apple Arcade ist der einzige Ort,
wo man unbegrenzt
über 100 grundlegende
exklusive neue Spiele
für iPhone, iPad, Mac
und Apple TV erhält.
Ihr könnt diese Spiele auf
jeder anderen mobilen Plattform
oder Subscription-Service eröffnen.
Kein Spiele-Service hat jemals
so viele Spiele auf einmal eröffnet.
Und wir warten nicht auf euch,
sie alle zu spielen.
Statt für jede Spiele
zu bezahlen,
lässt sich eure Subscription
für jede Apple Arcade Spiele
aus der App Store eröffnen.
Es beginnt mit der brandneuen
Arcade-Tab der App Store,
wo ihr die neuesten
Spiele jedes Monat eröffnen könnt.
Ihr bekommt persönliche
Empfehlungen,
Game-Trailers und
Experten-Editorial-Kontent,
wie Spiele-Guides und Sneak Peeks.
Diese Menge von
tollen Spielen
betrifft so viele Genres
und Spielstile,
dass alle in der Familie
auf Apple Arcade
Spiele finden können.
Wir freuen uns,
euch heute einige zu zeigen.
Wir haben die Spiele
für Jahrzehnte erfreut.
Ihr nächstes Spiel wird
sicherlich für die ganze Familie
ein Hits sein.
Bitte begrüßen Sie
Konami-Brandmanager Benjamin Kinney
um euch mehr zu erzählen.
Danke Anne.
Jeder liebt Frogger.
Deswegen zusammen mit Q-Games
können Konami nicht mehr
auf unsere Titel bringen,
dass Apple Arcade Frogger
eine Art Spiele-Programm
im Spiel ist.
In diesem Level
finden wir uns in Bastard
und Frogger muss seine
Froglet-Freunden retten.
Wie im klassischen Frogger
gibt es viele Herausforderungen.
Aber jetzt kann man Power-Ups finden,
wie dieses Bob,
das wir benutzen,
um den Weg voran zu klären.
Ihr werdet auch wissen,
dass wir Jellys sammeln.
Das ist eine lustige und wichtige
Schau, wir haben einen anderen Frogbeck-Freund gerettet.
Du wirst tausende verschiedene Outfits haben, in die du deinen Frogbeck einbauen kannst.
Heute haben wir diesen wunderschönen Badezimmer gekauft. Ist er nicht süß?
Ist das ein riesiges Baby, das Sunglasses trägt? Er macht einen Schmuck.
Lass uns versuchen, ihn umzugehen.
Erinnert du dich an die Gelatine, die wir vorhin hatten?
Na ja, wenn du 100 ausgibst, entlässt du den Super-Froggler.
Ich habe genug Fakten. Wir haben den letzten Frogbeck zu retten.
Und wir haben es geschafft. Guter Job!
Und wir können nicht warten, dass du mit deinen Freunden und Familie
exklusiv auf Apple Arcade spielst. Vielen Dank.
Danke, Benjamin. Der Frogbeck sieht wunderschön aus.
Nächster Schritt ist das legendäre Game-Studio Capcom.
Sein neues Spiel bringt Konsole-Qualität, Grafik und Gameplay zu einem ganz neuen Publikum.
Um mehr zu erzählen, willkommen Capcom-Produzent Peter Fabiani.
Vielen Dank, Sam.
Mit Shinsekai in die Dunkelheit setzen wir uns heraus,
um ein wunderschönes, aber tristes Unterwasser-Welt zu erschaffen.
Das Weltabend ist in Eis befestigt.
Du hast keine Wahl, sondern den Ozean unterhalb zu suchen.
Das ist die letzte Überlebende der Menschheit.
Du wirst die Gage auf der Spitze bemerken,
die zeigen, dass du sicher, gesund und tot bist.
Du musst vorsichtig und vorsichtig sein,
sobald du das neue Weltbeginn überlebst.
Du kannst mit Thrustern navigieren oder dich sicher machen.
Während des Suchens nach Ressourcen
sind unsere Explorers furchtbare Kreaturen.
Deshalb ist es immer wichtig,
dass du deine Obstkomponenten behältst.
Warten Sie auf uns.
Unser kleines Drone ist hier, um uns zu helfen.
Wir haben jeden Detail des Weltes geschaffen,
um es authentisch und immersiv zu machen.
In Wahrheit haben wir Musik und Soundeffekte unter Wasser gedreht.
Lasst uns es mal hören.
Unter Wasser?
Bestimmt war jemand in der Badewanne oder so.
Hat es Fisch-KI?
Was meint ihr, hat es Fisch-KI?
Shinsenkais Kontrollen sind einfach,
aber das Schießen während des Thrustens
wird sogar die größte Spielerin ermöglichen.
Die Unterwasserphysik und die unvergleichbaren Angriffe der Kreaturen
machen den Kampf entweder herausfordernd oder schmerzhaft.
Du wirst herausfinden, was als Nächstes passiert,
wenn du Shinsenkai in die Erde spielst.
Und die größte Frage, die man sich wieder stellen muss, ist,
ob es einfach oder später nicht läuft.
Macht aber eigentlich auch keinen Unterschied,
weil es war so und so nichts Tolles.
Wir bringen unsere Art von Spiele-Design
zu einer neuen, breiteren, globalen Publikation,
sowohl zuhause als auch mobil.
Nur auf Apple Arcade.
Danke.
Da ist Tim Cook zu jedem persönlich vorher
und hat gesagt, Leute,
sagt auf jeden Fall nur auf Apple Arcade.
Unsere letzten Spiele sind für innovative Spiele,
die den Mold brechen.
Unser nächstes Spiel ist wirklich einerartig.
Um mehr zu erzählen,
bitte begrüßen Sie Anapurna Interactive-Produzentin
Kelsey Hanson.
Anapurna.
Das hört sich an wie Katzennahrung, so ein bisschen.
Wir teamen mit Somogo zusammen,
um ihr kreatives, ambitiöses neues Spiel
auf Apple Arcade zu bringen.
Sayonara Wild Hearts ist ein schnelles,
Neon-Pop-Musik-Dreamscape.
Wir wollen es als ein spielbares Musikvideo denken.
Lasst uns rein.
Neon-Pop-Musik-Dreamscape.
Oh ja.
Das ist im Endeffekt Jungle.
Wie heißt das?
Temple Run?
Jungle Run?
Wie hieß das?
Temple Run, genau.
Bloß mit anderen Farben.
Na, dafür kann man doch schon mal
einen Game Pass kaufen.
Es hat auch ein bisschen was von Guitar Hero.
Ein bisschen was von Monster Hunter.
von Gita Hero mit der Straße. Was zum Teufel? Gucken wir uns da an?
Aber ich mag Stereo. Stereo ist gut. Stereo ist besser als Mono. Und Stereo ist sogar
noch besser als 5.1, wenn man keinen 5.1 hat. Die sagt nicht Heroin. Die sagt Heldin.
Chat alle. Warte mal, wer ist da? Zu schnell. Also nächste Woche, wo gerade Modern Warfare
Beta ist.
Kostet?
Naja, ganz ehrlich, wenn man auf Mobile Games steht. Das ist okay. Ich habe jetzt auch
gedacht, das kostet 20 Euro im Monat oder sowas.
Das kostet soviel wie Nintendo Online.
Oder ich weiß nicht, wie dieser Switch-Service heißt. Das kostet auch soviel, oder?
Apple Arcade ist ein Gaming-Service, wie jeder andere. Wir können nicht warten, zu
anfangen, wenn es später dieses Monat lautet.
Nächster Punkt, sprich Apple TV+.
Oh ja. Ich habe noch nicht mein normales Apple TV ohne Plus.
Unsere Mission für Apple TV Plus ist, euch das beste Erlebnis für die Zeit zu bringen,
Bring you the best original stories from the most creative minds in television.
400 Viewer, alter Leute, was ist los?
Rock.
Stories that help you find inspiration, that are grounded in emotion.
Truly stories to believe in.
Stories with purpose.
This summer we released three trailers for a few of our premiere originals.
Like For All Mankind, an innovative reimagination of the space race.
And Dickinson, starring Hailee Steinfeld, a coming-of-age story about Emily Dickinson,
told in a completely modern way.
And The Morning Show, with its blockbuster cast starring Reese Witherspoon, Steve Carell
and Jennifer Aniston in her first TV series since Friends.
The reaction to these trailers has been incredible.
They've been viewed over a hundred million times.
Thank you.
In fact, the trailer for The Morning Show is one of the most watched trailers for any new television show ever.
Ever.
This is incredible.
And the new issue of Entertainment Weekly calls The Morning Show Fall's most anticipated series.
Okay, jetzt feiern sie sich aber schon hart.
This morning I want to share with you one of the most imaginative, thrilling and thought-provoking dramas ever.
Seastars Jason Momoa.
And it takes place...
No, this is Ocean Man, right?
...in a world without sight.
Ocean Man.
We worked with blind and low-vision cast, crew and consultants who provided the detail and the authenticity for how this world should be defined.
Today I am so excited to share with you the worldwide premiere trailer for Sea.
Okay.
Centuries from now, almost all humans have lost the ability to see.
Some say sight was taken from them by God.
Einfach eine Runde beten, dann kommt das wieder.
For the few who remain, vision is only a myth.
But after so many years, the power of sight has returned.
Einfach so.
What is it?
Something's different.
The children, they have the ability.
To see.
My children, they have a power that we would call magical or evil.
We must protect them.
For centuries, we feared this day would come.
The evil of light once almost destroyed the world.
And now it has returned.
Find the children who can see.
And bring some to me.
If we give the babies, they might leave us alone.
No.
I stand with Boba Boss.
The trailer music.
The children are a gift.
They will bring knowledge.
They will begin a new world.
We are family.
We are one.
And we fight as one.
As one nation alone.
They belong to us!
With those hands.
To these years, and with the black
poetry.
Elite.
It will never break.
Lead.
Headless.
Brave.
Let's best 부달.
Give way.
Wo du den Trailer gesehen hast und im Endeffekt weißt du, wie der Film ausgeht.
Ach, das ist eine Serie?
Ah.
Also ich freue mich ja am meisten auf Hipsters.
Und Deutschland?
Da habe ich ja noch genug Geld, um mir die Arcade-Flatrate zu leisten.
Ja, das ist günstig. Also kommt auf den Inhalt an, ne?
Alter, ich habe vor zwei Wochen mein iPhone.
Vor zwei Wochen.
Aber ich wusste es eh nicht, dass ich es bezahle. Also insofern, who cares?
Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Ich wusste, was man mit dem iPad tun kann, weiter als je zuvor mit der Vorstellung von iPadOS.
Ja, das war gut.
iPadOS ist ein advanced operating system with a new name to recognize the distinctive experience of iPad.
Of course, iPadOS builds on the same foundation as iOS, but adds powerful new capabilities and intuitive features that are specific to the large display and versatility of the iPad.
iPad's unique integration of hardware software with over 1 million apps that are specifically designed to take advantage of the large canvas provide an experience that you won't find on any other device out there.
We have never been more excited about the future of iPad.
And to tell you about the newest iPad, I'd like to invite Joss to the stage.
Joss.
Ja, dazu.
Zeig mal her, da bin ich jetzt echt gespannt.
Das Einzige von Apple, was ich mir bisher selbst gekauft habe, ein iPad.
Ich glaube, das habe ich.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was ich mir gekauft habe.
Richtig.
Was ist das für eine Logik? Bei Apple kommt 7 nach 6. Das ist überhaupt nicht mal angesagt.
This is a big upgrade with some great new features and it's designed to make the most out of iPadOS.
Of course, iPad is a magical piece of glass. It can become almost anything we want it to be.
So the display is so important to the iPad experience.
Oh, das wird dann aber ein bisschen teurer.
Da ist nichts mehr mit 4,99 Millionen Pixeln.
Surface.
Lol.
Dafür läuft auf dem Surface alles.
Aber hat es RTX On?
Ist doch die Preisfrage.
Kann es Raytracing?
Das sieht aber hübsch aus.
Desktop Class Browsing.
Browsing, glaube ich erst, wenn ich es sehe.
Browser verkackt Apple seit Jahren auf Mobile.
Okay.
Or you can swipe along the bottom to get between multiple spaces, you can even use the same
app like notes across multiple spaces and paired with different apps.
It's perfect for working on multiple projects.
Safari brings desktop Class Browsing to iPad.
Das glaube ich euch nicht.
That's only way to create a website and square space.
Or edit your documents in Google Docs right in Safari.
And with a simple, simple pinch on the soft keyboard, a new floating keyboard appears.
Okay, das ist ganz nice.
Vor allem, dass es da ist, wo der Daumen ist, finde ich gut.
Oh, das ist cool.
Das ist cool.
Das ist wirklich gut.
USB-Stick anschließen.
Das ist Bock.
Ich meine, unter Android geht das, glaube ich, schon eine Weile, wenn du einen passenden Adapter hast, aber das ist nice.
Ach, stimmt, kein USB.
Die bildet.
Ich mache nichts davon auf meinem iPad.
Ich will aber 4,99 bezahlen.
Das ist das neue siebente Generation iPad.
10,2-Inch-Retina-Display, Unterstützung für Apple-Pencil und ein volles Smart-Keyboard.
Und wie du erwartest, gute Kameras, Sensoren und ultra-fröhliches Wireless,
alle verpackt in einem dünnen und leichten Design, der durchschnittlich und um einen Pound wächst.
Und für das erste Mal ist unsere Entschlussung von 100% recycelt.
Wir sind wirklich froh, dass wir uns weiterentwickeln können, um unsere wirtschaftlichen Erlebnisse zu erweitern.
Für das ist unser populärster iPad.
Wir sind auch froh, dass wir mit all diesen Verbesserungen, dieser neuen iPad, nur 329 Dollar starten werden.
Wenn du über all die Dinge denkst, die dieser iPad tun kann, können wir nicht über ein anderes Gerät denken, das so viel Wert erhält.
Und für unsere Education-Kustomer ist es noch mehr erfreulich, wenn es 299 Euro kostet.
Und du kannst auch, da ist es, du kannst es heute bestellen und es wird am Ende des Monats starten.
Es hat wirklich eine große Bedeutung.
Es war ein großartiges Jahr für das iPad.
Dieses neue iPad verbindet das neue iPad Mini, das neue iPad Air und das neue iPad Pro.
Alle wurden mit dem iPad OS weiterentwickelt als jemals vorher.
Das war die News für das iPad.
Jetzt zurück zu Tim.
Eine Uni-Mail reicht?
Mein alter Kumpel aus Dresden arbeitet an der Uni.
Oder also fast.
Nice.
Education-E-Mail-Link.
Nächstes Mal sprechen wir über das Apple Watch.
Oh nee.
Das ist eines der uselessen Produkte, außer wenn man Sport macht, ever.
Apple Watch hält groundbreaking health, fitness and communication capabilities onto the wrists of millions and millions of people.
Today Apple Watch is everywhere.
And it's making a difference in so many ways all over the world.
Stimmt.
Das hättet ihr gerne.
We hear first hand every day about the truly personal and profound impacts that the Apple Watch is having on people's lives.
So we made a video for you this morning to show you.
To share just some of these stories with you.
Okay.
Im Endeffekt, wir haben noch nicht begriffen, warum das geil ist.
Das zeigen sie uns jetzt nochmal.
Dear Mr. Cook.
Dear Apple.
Dear Tim.
Toontee Cook at Apple.com.
The Apple-Pepega-Fanboy-Army setzt sich in Bewegung.
Hey, how you doing?
Hi.
Hey, good morning.
Nice to meet you.
Okay, hello.
So, the run began as usual.
I was 32 weeks pregnant.
Getting ready to go to bed.
The next morning I'd have notifications on my watch in my phone saying.
Your heart rate is elevated.
And I was like, huh.
Huh, that's strange.
And I run my EKG and it says 220 beats.
And I'm like, something's not right.
I told my husband, like, we need to go.
He was like, well, I'm in the middle of cutting grass.
I'm like, we need to go.
And then suddenly I woke up to EMTs.
Oh, this is my husband, Kyle.
Hey.
He's going out to cut the grass.
When I fell.
It automatically called 911.
And then it calls my wife.
Wollen die uns ernsthaft erzählen, die Frau hat nicht gemerkt, dass ihr Baby jetzt
langsamer kommt, ohne Apple Watch oder wie?
And what could have happened?
Jetzt ernsthaft?
Tut das nicht weh, wenn man Kinder kriegt?
Once we got to the hospital, they realized it was just for infection.
My heart rate was spiking.
And it was causing the baby's heart rate to get lower and lower.
So, emergency C-section.
And she was born.
Had I not had surgery, it estimated that I would have had an emergency C-section.
I would have had an emergency C-section.
It estimated that I would have had a heart attack within less than 12 months.
I mean, I have goosebumps.
I don't know if you can see them through the camera.
It's crazy.
It's not something you think of, your watch.
Saving your life.
Can you wave hi?
Das Kind wird sich freuen, wenn das irgendwann in 15 Jahren mal die Apple Keynote anguckt.
Vielleicht ist der Mann der Gärtner, ja?
In the past, I didn't prioritize taking care of myself.
Yeah, so these are one of the largest pairs of pants I have.
Das wischt ihr schon.
But now I've gained the ability to be active in ways that I never would have dreamed of.
All because the computer on my wrist told me it was time to fill the rings.
Yeah, closing rings.
It's like this little reminder going, okay, you can do a little better today.
When I see the little rings of like, get your moves in today.
Sometimes I used to be like, mind your business, Apple Watch.
But then it's like, you know what, I do need to get my movement.
I like the idea of achievements that you get for every small things done.
It has just reminded me I should stand up, by the way.
This data, that kind of endless power, that kind of feeling of pushing from behind.
Oh yeah.
I'm the Blur.
He's the Blur.
That's his nickname, is the Blur.
Harrison is on the autism spectrum and he's on the cross country and track teams here at the school.
He was having some issues with anxiety and crowd noise.
The sound of the cheering just throws me off.
So, I paired up my watch with my headphones.
And the music helps me.
Focus.
When he started running, what music playing was like seeing a different athlete.
This moment of triumph, goosebumps and tears and it was cinematic.
Apple needs to know this happened.
What you did in your brainstorming sessions came to life and helped save mine.
Dear Apple, dear Mr. Cook, I just had to tell my story.
I will be forever grateful.
I had no idea that one day it would save my life.
Oh, meine Güte, wie sie sich abfeiern.
Thank you.
Wie sie sich abfeiern.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch, dass sie so einen Typ auf die Bühne holen und interviewen oder
sowas.
Dann wäre das perfekt.
They see the difference that the Apple Watch is making.
Hearing these stories really make my heart sing.
And these are just a few of the amazing stories that I get every day.
Hm.
In addition to helping individuals, Apple Watch is having an impact on another important
area that affects all of us.
And that is health research.
We're excited about how Apple Watch can make a tremendous difference in this area.
And to tell you more about it, I'd like to invite Sumbul to the stage.
Sumbul.
What makes the amazing stories you just saw even possible are the incredible capabilities
built into Apple Watch.
Each one requires sensitivity.
Ja.
So, what makes Apple Watch more important is the development and research.
This deep focus is designed to
establish new information for any of our product features, especially the ones focused on health.
For example, the irregular heart rhythm notification was developed using the data from the largest
Was, die Hose? Was ist mit der Hose, Leute?
Die Hose? Ja, es ist halt betont oben und unten, betont nicht betont.
Da müsst ihr mal bei uns ins Rechenzentrum gehen mit.
Wahrscheinlich darfst du das dann wieder nicht auf die Arbeit anziehen,
weil du die Leute abhören könntest.
Na klar.
Na klar, ich werde weniger krank mit der Apple Watch.
Das Einzige, was das bringt, ist, wenn du regelmäßig Sport machst,
wenn du irgendwie Ausdauergeschichten machst,
dass du einfach ordentlich gucken kannst,
wie sich deine Herzfrequenz entwickelt und so.
Das ist okay.
Diese ganzen Sachen mit, dass du nicht merkst, wenn du schwanger bist,
oder dass du nicht mehr so viel Wissen hast,
dass du nicht mehr so viel Wissen hast,
oder dass du nicht merkst, wenn du kurz vorm Verrecken bist,
dass dich dann die Apple Watch rettet, ist kompletter Blödsinn.
Oh Mann, 08.
18, danke schön.
So, I hope that you check it out.
Since the beginning, innovation has been the core of the Apple Watch.
Innovations that really matter to people.
From the life-changing to the potentially life-savings.
Many of these technologies were barely imaginable...
Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber echt.
Apple Watch has become the most advanced
and most loved smart watch in the world.
And to tell you all about what's next with the Apple Watch,
I'd like to invite up...
Stan Ng.
Stan.
45 Jaws, danke schön, Rich Prime.
We want to make Apple Watch even better
for all the things you do and places you go.
500 Viewer, the fuck?
And so today, I'm so excited to share with you
the next generation of Apple Watch.
Asterix99, danke schön.
Alter, die Musik ist viel zu laut.
Wonka S.
Okay, was?
Genau.
Was exakt sagt uns das jetzt?
Ups.
Hä?
Ah.
Nice, ich hab eine Uhr, wo ich permanent eine Uhr sehe.
Aber das ist wirklich ganz cool für Leute mit einer Apple Watch,
die sowas mögen.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist das neue Always-On Display?
Das ist einfach mit advanced technologies angeboten.
Ich will euch nochmal erzählen.
Es beginnt mit den industriellen,
nur mit dem Low-Temperature-Polysilicon- und Oxide Display,
oder LTPO.
LTPO ermöglicht das Display,
dynamisch nach wie vor zu refreshen,
von so hoch wie 60 Hertz
bis zu so hoch wie 1 Hertz,
was extrem effizient ist.
Es gibt auch ein neues Low-Power Display Driver,
ein ultra-effizienter,
Das ist gut. Also das gefällt mir.
Ich meine, ich habe immer noch persönlich keinen Anwendungszweck für, aber warum nicht?
Moment. Seit wann sind 18 Stunden eigentlich ein Tag?
Fällt mir gerade so ein.
Okay. Ja gut, warum nicht?
Ey, das ist, das ist ganz nett. Ja, warum nicht?
Okay.
So?
S υnder instruction this is.
Okay.
So.
Genau, genau.
Buy anyone this?
Yes please.
So.
Okay.
Now please.
Yeah.
Okay.
Und wie kalt das dann?
Das ist anscheinend voll angesagtes, die Dinger jetzt.
Ich mein nicht, dass ich was dagegen hätte.
Da wird wahrscheinlich immer noch vom AliExpress Chinesen im Käfig hergestellt oder so.
Aber recycelbar ist schon mal dann verkehrt.
Die Clutch noch für alles, oder? Es gibt jetzt eine weiße Farbe.
Wo ist die Jeezy's?
Jeezy's Apple Watch?
Wir haben auch Hermes-Modelle in schwarz eingeführt.
Mit schwarzem, schwarzem Stahlkasten.
Mit handgesteuerten Leatherbanden.
Oh, die sind einfach erstaunlich.
Natürlich ist jede Apple Watch in der regelmäßigen Art und Weise gestaltet und hergestellt.
Wir sind so gespannt auf die Apple Watch Series 5.
Sie ist immer auf Display.
Ich habe zwar nicht vor, mir eine Apple Watch zu kaufen, aber ich muss sagen,
und all die anderen tollen Features.
Es wäre jetzt zumindest technisch so, dass ich mir es kaufen würde.
Es sieht aus wie eine Badematte.
Wie so ein Badematte, wie so ein Duschvorleger.
Wir haben es in vielen Storys, von Anfang September 20.
Wir halten auch die sehr populäre Series 3 in der Linie.
Die Series 3 ist eine tolle Watch.
Sie hat ein GPS, ein Heart Rate Sensor.
Sie ist schwimmfähig.
Die neuen Features der WatchOS 6.
Und jetzt beginnt sie mit einem niedrigen Preis von nur 1,99 Euro.
Das ist doch was.
Was ist mit Apple los?
Das kann man sich ja alles kaufen.
Und das ist die Apple Watch.
Danke.
Zurück zu dir, Tim.
Danke, Stan.
Ich freue mich wirklich auf diese neue Apple Watch Line-Up.
Und mit all den neuen tollen Features,
wird die Apple Watch Sie noch mehr machen können als vorher.
Wir haben ein lustiges Video geschaffen, um nur das zu zeigen.
Ich würde es gerne für Sie jetzt spielen.
Oh, ein lustiges Video.
Ich erwarte eine Runde Chris.
Diese Watch erzählt Zeit.
Mach mit.
Und ruft an.
Diese Watch erzählt Zeit.
Schaltet die Lichter an.
Und öffnet die Türen.
Diese Watch erzählt Zeit.
Und kommuniziert mit Satelliten.
12.427 Meilen über der Erde.
Nein.
Sie wacht dich auf.
Das stimmt nicht.
GPS kommuniziert nicht mit Satelliten.
So funktioniert das mit GPS nicht.
Hey Siri, spiel Tumbleweed Connection.
Es wird nie gedreht.
Spiel Goodbye, Yellow Brick Road.
Sag Madman Across the Water.
Doch, Max.
Diese Watch erzählt Zeit.
Und setzt Timer.
GPS ist nur zum Lesen.
Und berät dich, wenn es zu laut ist.
Und schreibt deinen Freunden.
Und öffnet Portale.
Verrückt.
Und trackt deine Distanz unter Wasser.
Und startet Wettbewerbe.
Und akzeptiert Herausforderungen.
Und trackt deine Workouts.
Und erzählt dir, in welcher Richtung du gehen solltest.
Es gibt eine App, die den richtigen Timing der elektrischen Wäsche betrifft,
die durch die oberen und unteren Zellen deines Herzens fliegt.
Andererseits bekannt als Elektro-Kardiogramm.
Soll ich das wiederholen?
Diese Watch.
Diese.
Watch.
Erzählt.
Zeit.
Unter anderem andere Dinge.
EKG.
The fuck.
Apple Watch mit DeFi wäre doch auch mal was.
Kannst halt wie im Battlefield hingehen.
I love that video.
Helpt you understand so many of the amazing things that the watch can do.
Next stop.
Let's talk about iPhone.
Ja, jetzt zeig mal her.
Mal gucken, ob ich mir umsonst einen Zehner geholfen habe.
The incredible capabilities that it puts into people's hands
has changed the way we live our lives in ways that we never could have imagined.
It's become so essential for hundreds and hundreds of millions of people all over the world.
It changed industries and led to the creation of entirely new ones
and it's made a profound impact on all of our daily lives.
Customers love iPhone and we keep striving to make it better and better.
Last year we launched three incredible iPhones.
The iPhone XR became the most popular iPhone and the most popular smartphone in the world.
Welches?
Ist das das, was ich habe?
We also launched the iPhone XS and the iPhone XS Max, the most advanced iPhones we have ever created.
XR.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein XR, oder?
XR?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ich habe es auf Twitter gepostet.
Customer satisfaction.
Ja, ja, ist klar.
It's a fact in the industry.
Really unbelievable.
Customers love iPhone because we focus on technologies that matter most in their lives.
Today I am thrilled to share with you the newest iPhone.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Poggers.
Zwei Kameras.
Hat meins auch schon zwei Kameras, wenn ich eine Zähne habe?
Ich habe es noch nicht ausgepackt.
Das steht seit einer Woche hier.
Ich wollte, Leute, ich muss mal mein iPhone schnell auspacken.
The next generation of iPhone and it is jam-packed with great new capabilities and an incredible new design.
To tell you all about iPhone 11, I'd like to invite Cayenne to the stage.
Cayenne?
Ich muss mein iPhone auspacken.
Ich muss es mal vergleichen.
Thank you, Tim.
The animations in iPhone 11 are truly remarkable.
Oh, wo ist es?
Boah.
And that starts with the design.
iPhone 11 has a beautiful anodized aluminum.
Nee, meins hat nur eine Kamera hinten.
And that glass is the toughest ever in a smartphone, on the front and back.
And the glass that surrounds the camera has a sculpted 3D geometry.
And it was precision milled down from a single piece of glass to achieve this elegant look.
iPhone 11 comes in six new colors with an all-new purple, white, yellow, green, black and product red.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich für ein iPhone hab.
Das steht nicht drauf.
Da steht einfach nur iPhone drauf.
Und es ist schwarz.
It has a 6.1-inch liquid retina display with true tone, wide color, tapped away.
Ich hab ein XR?
Okay, ich hab ein XR.
Ihr wisst das besser als ich.
Nice.
Good job.
Now, videos are wonderful to watch on this display.
And now we have spatial audio, which provides an immersive theater-like experience by creating a sound field around you using an Apple-designed virtualizer.
What?
And we support Dolby Atmos for an incredible sound experience.
Now let's talk about camera.
iPhone is the world's most popular camera and it gets even better with iPhone 11.
Sound experience.
Dass die Leute in der Bar noch besser Haftbefehl hören können.
Haha.
Und wir haben einen neuen Ultra-Wide-Kamera mit 120°-Field of view.
Das wird euch viel mehr in euren Fotos und Videos erzeugen lassen.
Denn jetzt könnt ihr eine Wide-Kamera-Fotografie so machen, aber switchen zu der Ultra-Wide-Fotografie,
um die Scale zu zeigen.
Ja.
Okay.
Und jetzt seht ihr das wunderschöne Framing meiner Mutter Natur.
Aber die Details sind immer noch da.
In der Höhe der Steine.
Immersive
Ja, ich fühle mich auch gleich wie am Strand
Ach, die zweite Kamera
ist
wide oder was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Wieso soll ich das wissen?
Mein iPhone hat nur eine Kamera
die man mit Detail auszeichnen kann
therefore it looks even better
Wir nutzen das auf allen von Ihren Fotos
und auch in unserer next gen Smart HDR
Sie sehen den wunderschönen Lachtrainschild
und ihr warmes Gesicht
akzentuiert vom sonnet참terschwein
Wir nutzen mithilfe des Multiscales Tonmappings
um die Highlights anders zu teilen
in verschiedenen Teilen des Bildes
abhängig davon, was ihnen am besten ist
Es funktioniert hier im Portrait Modus
und die Leute lieben es
auf den iPhone 11 Portrait zu nehmen
Und iPhone 11 hat eine große Maschine
angle camera. So you can take these beautiful wide shots of portraits for people. But now
with two cameras we have stereoscopic depth. So now you can also take portraits of your
favorite pets. And you can also use creative depth of field for shots like this. Now we
have a new portrait lighting effect and that's high key mono. You can take a stunning studio
quality portrait like this from a pretty ordinary background. All right, let's talk
about night mode. This is for those very low light environments like outdoors at night
or inside a dimly lit restaurant. And night mode comes on automatically when it's dark
enough to brighten photos and reduce noise. Here's an image with night mode turned off.
Here it is with night mode turned on.
Ich bin skeptisch.
Ob das so ausschaut. Weil ich finde die, die Lampe rechts sieht auch viel heller aus, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut funktioniert.
Okay, gibt's schon. Aha, okay.
Okay.
On our wide and ultra wide cameras.
Komm, jetzt Beats Lautsprecher. Das ist das neue Apple Auto. IK.
Das originale iSnow.
So the quality is just astounding. That was shot in 4K resolution. And all the shots including
the ones overhead were hand held. So it's making use of our even better cinematic video
stabilization.
Also, you can easily tap to switch to the ultra wide camera to capture even more in your scene.
Das Video ist nicht synchron, oder?
You can also use the zoom wheel to just transition easily between the two cameras.
To capture in all the formats you love.
Jetzt ist wieder synchron.
Because we support 4K resolution up to 60 frames per second. Slow-mo, time lapse, cinematic
video stabilization. And now extended dynamic range at 4K up to 60 frames per second. And
this is across both cameras.
Gut, man muss sagen, also in den letzten Jahren hat es da wirklich viel getan. Die
Bilder von dem Smartphone, Josefine, das ist immer noch mein Smartphone, sehen mittlerweile
wirklich saumäßig gut aus.
We also wanted to make it easier for you to take a quick video with QuickTake.
With QuickTake?
So now when you're taking photos and you decide you want to take a quick video, simply tap
and hold the shutter button to record a video. You can do that without changing frames.
Jawohl, das hat mal einmal zwei Zeilen Code dazu programmiert. Poggers.
So video really shines.
In fact, it has the highest quality video ever in a Smartphone.
Das legt wer fest? Apple, oder was?
Ich leg auch fest, Max macht die besten YouTube-Videos.
It's enabled by our real-time processing across our camera hardware, our software, our video
encoders, and our chip.
So that's the amazing dual camera system on iPhone 11. With a new wide and ultra-wide
for 2x optical zoom out, night mode, a brighter flash, next-gen smart HDR.
And the highest quality video. It will change the way you take your photos and videos.
Ach, das hat einen Blitz jetzt, okay.
We've also updated our front TrueDepth camera to a wider 12-megapixel sensor.
So now you can still take your 7-megapixel selfies as you normally would, but simply rotate
to landscape to capture even more people using that wider sensor.
Triple, triple, wobei das ist dann kein Selfie mehr.
Also on the front camera we've added 4K video with extended dynamic range up to 30 frames per second.
And you can also capture on the front at 4K 60 as well.
Now we've also added slow motion video to the front camera for the first time.
Now we think this is gonna be really fun. So fun that we created a little ad about it
and we couldn't resist showing you.
Oh, noch ein Video. Let's go.
Was zum Teufel geht jetzt ab?
Aha, das ist für die Instagram-Grills, die sich fotografieren müssen.
Alright, now so much of our great camera is also enabled by performance.
And iPhone 11 has leading performance for your everyday to the most demanding task.
In fact, our Apple design chips have led the industry for many years.
Ben says the A12 is so far ahead of the industry that it will still be competitive
with the best Android smartphones in the world.
Well now we're introducing the A13 Bionic, the next generation of our industry leading chip.
Aber die Apple CPUs sind wirklich extrem gut.
So if you look at CPU performance, with the iPhone XR's A12 Bionic chip,
it still leads the pack in terms of the latest smartphones.
Well, the A13 Bionic is just gonna extend that lead even further.
The A13 is the fastest CPU ever in a smartphone.
Ich glaub das.
Ich glaub den.
Also, es ist nicht so, dass ich in das Pauschal nicht glauben würde,
weil die Apple CPUs sind wirklich gut.
Aber ich hätte gerne mal unabhängig nen Benchmark.
So what about graphics?
Well, if you look at the A12, it's still leading in task in GPU performance.
And the A13 Bionic is just gonna get even faster.
Because the A13 Bionic is also the fastest GPU ever in a smartphone.
Da kann ich Frogger, Frogger im 8K spielen.
I can show you more about that, because this is great for mobile gaming.
I'd like to introduce Giant Network.
They are the force behind some of the most popular mobile games in China.
And now with their studio, TipsWorks, they're preparing to release their first global title.
It's called Pascal's Wager, and I'd like to introduce Yang Yang, the founder of TipsWorks.
Die Frage ist, sagen wir mal wieder, die man sich jetzt stellen muss,
kann die GPU wenigstens RTX on?
We have been working on an exciting action role-playing game.
Let's take a look.
Pascal's Wager is a dark fantasy action game.
It will take on the journey through a massive world.
Asia RPG, damit gecrined, sag ich euch.
And the humans must make a pass by staying close to giants that illuminate.
Der Mobile-Bedienung.
Kack-Touch-Bedienung, ey.
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein Game, was gar nicht übel ist.
Und sich mit dem Controller tausendmal besser spielen würde.
Huge Kampfsystem.
Players can select one of four characters.
And can change throughout to use different skills.
Now we've changed it to Benita, whose powerful web can take on enemies' memories.
Moment, ich denke, die Leute sehen jetzt wieder was.
Warum seht ihr nix?
We spend hours recreating the perfect sounds of footsteps, chains and even blades clashing.
Details are clear with the iPhone's spatial audio.
Let's watch as Benita fights this monster.
Also ich glaube mit Controller wäre das besser.
As we trail the hour, we see the benefits of photoprocessing effects, including anti-aliasing and bloom.
Which are only impossible with the GPU of the new iPad.
Anti-aliasing, Poggers, das ist ja...
Das gibt's ja noch gar nicht sonst.
Nie da gewesen.
Und Bloom braucht kein Mensch.
Ja.
That's right.
Kommt jetzt God of War.
Next one.
Yes.
I want Mobile LOVE
A little, some снitch.
It's a good Octo out of 20ap.
So.
Yes.
Wow, light!
That's true!
Das Einzige, was ich mobil spiele, ab und zu mal, ist Hearthstone.
Kann man darauf auch Diablo Mobile spielen dann?
Mehr Akku ist immer gut.
Eine Stunde mehr, wahrscheinlich bei nichts tun.
Wi-Fi 6? Ja, das Witzige ist, dass es noch nicht mal fertig standardisiert ist und alle machen es schon.
Oh Leute, ich muss mal aufs Klo, aber das geht jetzt nicht.
Oh.
Die Musik, Alter!
Nicht Grumpy Cat.
Alter, die Musik!
Zwei Meter für 30 Minuten.
Also kann man mit...
Ich kann jetzt duschen gehen mit meinem iPhone.
Huge!
Dann kann ich Twitch-Streams gucken oder dusche.
Das ist wenig... Das ist mal was!
Wenn das klappt, wäre das mega geil!
Ich mache das jetzt immer so, dass ich mein Tablet vor die Duschwand hänge.
Vor die... Vor die...
Also, vor die Glaswand.
Ja.
Damit ich mit Gamer-Grills ankomme.
Damit ich mit conspiracy-Twitch gucken kann.
Alter! Ist das laut!
Was ist das? XR, ist das auch...
Ist das auch wasserdicht? Ja...
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Nur, weil ich hier ein XR liegen habe, heißt das doch nicht, dass ich Ahnung voll habe, was das XR kann?
Ach so.
Ja, mein 6er war nicht wasserdicht.
Das ist, was ist mit Apple los?
Was ist mit Apple los?
Was ist da los?
Warum ist das so billig?
Ja okay, das fängt an.
Das fängt an bei 6,99.
Die ordentliche Version kostet wahrscheinlich 2.000 oder so.
iPhone 12.
iPhone Plus.
iPhone Pro.
iPhone X-Box.
iPhone Mac.
iPhone Magenta Gaming Edition.
Oh, jetzt kommt das mit drei Kameras.
Jetzt kommt das mit drei Kameras.
Alter, sieht das scheiße aus.
Bro, jawoll.
Huge.
Aber, das war G-Bait.
Das war der übelste G-Bait, dass das andere so billig ist.
Das war der übelste G-Bait, weil das ist das eigentlich, was teuer wird.
Und diese sind die am stärksten und am erfolgreichsten iPhones, die wir jemals gebaut haben.
In einem erstaunlichen neuen Design.
Ich möchte Phil anrufen, um euch alles über ihn zu erzählen.
Phil!
Oh, Phil, gib's uns.
Das ist das erste Smartphone, das wir als Pro genannt haben.
Und für uns bedeutet das, dass es ein Gerät ist, mit dem wir die Namen ausgehen.
Um das Werk zu erreichen.
Aber es ist auch ein Produkt für alle.
Für alle von uns, die einfach das beste Produkt machen wollen.
Selbst wenn wir kein Pro sind.
Also, lasst uns darüber reden.
Wir fangen mit diesem unglaublich erstaunlichen neuen Pro-Design an.
Das ist das am erfolgreichste iPhone, das wir jemals gebaut haben.
Es ist aus einem klinischen Stahl, aus dem man einen einzigen Stück Maschinenglas hat.
Mit einem optischen PVD-Coding.
Es hat einen wunderschönen, matten, texturierten Finis.
Der sieht großartig aus und fühlt sich großartig an in der Hand.
Das iPhone 11 Pro kommt mit einigen wunderschönen neuen Finis.
Das ist ein ganz neues Mittwochgrün.
Es ist ein sehr Pro-Spacegrün, ein wunderschönes Silber und ein neues Gold.
Das ist unglaublich.
Lass uns darüber reden über dieses Pro-Display.
Es kommt in zwei Größen.
5,8 Inch und 6,5 Inch.
Sie haben die höchste Pixel-Densität eines Displays.
Gut, nicht dass man das brauchen würde, aber muss ja.
Es ist ein neues OLED-Panel.
Es hat eine Kontrast-Ratio von 2 Millionen zu 1.
P3, breite Farbe, echte Farbe, haptische Anzeige.
Und jetzt ist es viel breiter, bis zu 1.200 Inch.
Das ist unglaublich breit, während es auch 15% effizienter ist.
Nun, dieses unglaubliche neues Display.
Es hat einen Niveau von 1.200 Inch.
Es hat eine Kontrast-Ratio, Farbe und Detail.
Aber wirklich ist es die Erfahrung, die wir in das neue Display für das Mac Pro bauen.
Wir nennen das das Pro-Display XDR.
Und jetzt wird diese Erfahrung in ein iPhone gebaut.
Außerdem hat es den spatialen Audio-Gesang, über den Cayenne gesprochen hat.
Es hat einen XDR10, Dolby Vision, Dolby Atmos.
Also haben wir uns entschieden, dass es einen neuen Namen wert ist.
Wir nennen es das Super Retina XDR Display.
Oh, das geht ja.
Das geht ja wie nichts von der Zunge.
Super Retina XDR.
Alright, let's talk about performance.
A pro-level performance.
As you know, our A-Series chips have kept Apple ahead of the industry for years now.
And the A13 Bionic is going to extend that lead.
We'll tell you even more about the A13 Bionic.
I'm really excited to bring up Shree Samthanam.
He's our Vice President of Silicon Engineering.
Shree?
Thank you, Phil.
Hello, everyone.
Our engineering team at Apple has been designing chips for iPhone for over a decade.
And today, I'm excited to talk to you about A13 Bionic, our latest creation.
And we have touched every...
Er hat ganz schön viel geübt, er ist richtig heiser.
Now, Apple, we have the benefit of owning the entire vertical stack.
The software, the system hardware, and the chip design.
And we work together to optimize every block on the chip.
All the way from the transistor up through the package design
to work efficiently for iOS and iPhone.
We've touched so many things and improved so many things in the A13 Bionic.
But today, I'd like to talk to you about two specific improvements.
Machine learning and low-power design.
First, machine learning.
We use machine learning all throughout iPhone.
And in our chips, our CPUs, GPUs, and more,
are all optimized for different types of machine learning workloads.
And in A13 Bionic, we made them all faster for ML.
Particularly for Intel.
Particularly the CPU.
We added brand new machine learning accelerators in our CPUs.
These accelerators are built to run matrix multiplication very fast.
That's an operation that's used frequently in ML computation.
These dedicated accelerators allow the CPU to process matrix math operations up to 6x faster.
Making the CPU capable of over 1 trillion operations per second.
Now, as developers experiment on the bleeding edge of ML,
the CPU can accelerate these nascent evolving models.
One trillion operations.
In addition, the chip works in our latest generation of the Apple-designed machine learning controller.
An ML model can be automatically and seamlessly scheduled on the CPU, GPU, and neural engine,
balancing efficiency and performance.
Together with the iPhone 11 Pro, this creates a fully integrated platform
where developers can do some incredible things,
like natural language processing,
image classification in photos and videos,
and character animation and people occlusion,
in AR-Apps.
All of this makes iPhone 11 Pro the best machine learning platform in any smartphone.
The second thing I'd like to talk to you today about is how we lowered the power of the 813 Bionic.
It is our most efficient chip today.
And here are a few reasons why.
First, it starts with the transistors, the fundamental building blocks of our chips.
An 813 Bionic uses an advanced, improved,
second generation 7 nanometer transistor.
The most advanced in the industry.
And we carefully tailor each transistor for high performance and low power.
And we did this with over eight and a half billion transistors.
That's the most we've ever put into any iPhone chip.
But it's not just the sheer volume of transistors.
To get both high performance and low power, you need great architecture.
One example of that is our Apple-architected,
high-efficiency CPU-Cores.
These cores are the most efficient place to run lightweight tasks
and powerful enough to use most of the time,
giving you great battery life.
Finally, at the design level, we applied many, many low-power design techniques
to increase the efficiency of our design.
For example, we have hundreds of voltage domains on the chip.
So we light up only the sections of the chip that need to function at any given time.
But that's not all.
We have hundreds of thousands of clock-hating domains.
So we only turn on the smallest amount of quality of the chip,
dramatically reducing power.
The result is our highest performing, most efficient design ever.
All of our cores, CPU, GPU and neural engine, are all up to 20% faster.
In addition, at the same time as we move performance up,
for those applications and tasks that don't need more performance in the A12,
we were able to reduce the power of all our engines.
For example, our GPU by up to 40%.
All of this translates to great performance and battery life for our customers.
And in addition...
The Apple Watch makes the emergency call for you.
... one of our best state performance ever.
And that's 813 Bionic.
It is our most efficient, most performant chip we have ever built for iPhone.
We can't wait for our customers and developers to see it in action.
Thank you and back to Phil.
Well, thank you Sri.
So, what has our team done to help the battery life
keep up with this incredible level of pro performance?
We are so excited to tell you that with iPhone 11 Pro
you now get up to 4 hours longer in your day.
Okay, moment, moment.
And...
The iPhone 11 Pro wraps up to 5 hours longer in your day.
We're also including our fast charged 18 watt adapter in the box
to charge them all faster too.
So...
I know what you're waiting for.
I am too.
Let's talk about the cameras.
Now a question, my favorite part about iPhone.
This is the first iPhone that we've had,
a camera system that we call Pro.
It's really worthy of this name.
So what does it have?
First, it has a new wide camera
that has a fast f1.8 aperture
and focus pixels that cover 100% of the sensor.
There's a new telephoto camera
with a larger f2.8 camera.
It has a 2.0 aperture.
It lets in 40% more light.
And has a new ultra wide camera
with a super wide 120 degree field of view
and a tremendous range of focus across the entire image.
Now all these work together
with the A13 Bionic chip
and its new generation image signal processor.
And that enables a whole new level of photography,
pro photography.
And you're just gonna love it.
So let's go...
First of all,
if you're a telephoto camera
and the ultra wide,
you have the ability to zoom in two times
and zoom out two times
and it's a 4x optical zoom range.
It's true cameras are incredible, creative,
but for example,
you can use the telephoto
and getting close on your subject
to really zoom in on it.
Or you can use the wide
to tell a bit more of a story.
Or you can pull all the way out
of the ultra wide
and reveal the full surroundings.
You can take all three shots
from one vantage point.
Now, we've given iPhone 11 Pro
to some pro photographers to use
to see what they can do
with this incredible new camera system.
And first, they absolutely love it
and they are excited to share with you
some of the photos they've taken.
So we've picked from all the incredible shots
they've taken six.
We're gonna go through six shots that pros have taken
to show you some of the different cameras
and what's possible.
And they're just stunning.
And here's a perfect one to start with.
Look at this image.
It is shot with a wide camera,
shot by Jordy Wood.
Shot it in a perfect named place for this photo.
Peekaboo Canyon in Kanab, Utah.
That's just the awesome name for this.
Look at the eye, the detail in the eye.
The details in the eyelashes,
the incredible skin tones.
This is a great photo to show
the power of this new camera system.
Here's another shot,
very different kind of shot,
also taken with that wide camera.
This was shot by Jake Michaels.
In L.A.
You can see he caught a moment frozen in time.
The fast shutter speed can capture the light
just bouncing off those frozen water droplets.
And it uses our black and white pro-level image filter,
which gives an incredible tonal gray scale to it.
All right, now let's switch over to the telephoto.
It's an incredible shot taken by Francesca Allen
out in Malibu.
Just see incredible image clarity,
stunning environment,
skin tones are beautiful,
shot by natural light.
And that's just the natural depth of field
of that aperture with F1.8, F2.0.
It is amazing.
And the blues of the sky and the water, just stunning.
So now let's look at a portrait mode shot
of the telephoto camera.
It's very different than what you would take.
This is backlit,
a backlit portrait mode telephoto shot
by Jake Michaels.
And you just see the incredible silhouette,
but so much detail in the hair.
Look at the blue and gold backlit,
just such vibrant colors.
A stunning image.
All right, now let's look at a photo taken
with our new ultra wide camera.
Jake Michaels took this down in Venice Beach
over a skateboard park.
How did he take this?
Got up on a cherry picker,
50 feet above the ground.
I think many of us would be a little nervous doing that,
but for us he did it.
Took a shot down with the wide angle,
the super wide camera.
Just see this incredible abstract image.
Looks stunning.
The focus is incredible
because of the depth of focus of that camera.
All right, one more example.
This is shot with the ultra wide
by Chiara Zonka.
Shot this in Arizona.
See this amazing contrast between the lights
and the darks and the midtones.
The sky.
The landscape is just surreal.
This is just this otherworldly shot
with all of the camera.
So those are six examples of photos
using the three cameras.
What pros can do if you put it in their hands
with their incredible talent,
it's amazing stuff.
Well now what we want to do,
yep, let's clap.
Ich frag mich halt,
wie ich gerade gesagt habe,
jemand der wirklich Profi-Fotos machen will,
der hat eine Kamera.
Now we want to give you a sneak peek
of a new feature coming in the camera
that will be available with a software update this fall,
but it's so cool we have to tell you about it.
It's using the neural engine of the A13 Bionic
to create a whole brand new kind of image processing system.
We call it Deep Fusion.
And this is so cool.
So to tell you what it's doing,
I'm going to do that while we look at an image.
So this is a photo that was shot on an iPhone 11 Pro
using this Deep Fusion technology.
And this kind of an image would not have been possible before.
We use machine learning to take this photo
in low to medium light.
And it's unlike anything possible
with an iPhone camera before.
So what is it doing?
Machine learning photo.
Alright, are you ready for this?
What it does, it shoots nine images.
Before you press the shutter button,
it's already shot four short images,
four secondary images.
When you press the shutter button,
it takes one long exposure.
And then in just one second,
the neural engine analyzes the fused combination
of long and short images,
picking the best among them,
selecting all the pixels,
and pixel by pixel going through 24 million pixels
to optimize for detail and low noise.
Like you see on the sweater there.
It is amazing.
This is the first time a neural engine
is responsible for generating the output image.
It is competition of photography mad science.
This is great cool.
But of course it is much better
to calculate the photo in the background
instead of recording it with a proper camera.
Alright, now let's talk about video.
iPhone 11 Pro is a powerful new video camera system.
All three cameras shoot 4K, 60 frames a second,
extended dynamic range video
with beautiful highlights and shadow details.
So of course we gave iPhone 11 Pro
to a professional cinematographer and director
and asked them to take it to a back lot in LA,
shoot something and show us all what's possible
with this brand new camera system.
And that's what we want to show you now.
Yeah.
Ich muss auch ein bisschen leiser machen,
die Videos sind aber übelst laut.
Übrigens Leute, wenn euch das Streamen gefällt,
habe ich euch schon erzählt,
dass wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime Account habt,
dass ihr den kostenlos verbinden könnt
mit Twitch
und dann einen Streamer eurer Wahl
kostenlos subscriben könnt.
Ihr bekommt alle Vorteile von einem regulären Sub.
Es kostet euch nichts.
Das heißt, ihr habt noch genug Geld,
euch Apple Arcade zu kaufen.
Oder wie hieß das andere?
Apple TV.
Außerdem ist September.
Da kostet das Ganze eh nur die Hälfte.
Next Level.
Roster HD, dankeschön, Muffin Man.
Danke Twitch Prime.
Bock.
Boltman, Satan.
Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
That was not only shot,
but also edited entirely on iPhone 11 Pro
by Director of Photography Guillermo Garza
and Director Diego Contreras.
This is a deadly enemy.
Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Nice.
Diese abonniert zwei Monate.
Dankeschön.
POG.
Steph Chris, zwei Monate.
Toter B.
Twitch Prime.
Ja, es funktioniert doch.
Pokémon Play.
Und in real time.
Take data from the camera you're shooting with
and edit other cameras automatically
for auto focus, auto exposure, color temperature,
even tone mapping.
So you can get a smooth transition across all three cameras
while we minimize any shifts in color or exposure.
And for pros who want to edit this video quickly on device.
Now with IOS 13
we have new advance video editing features
built into the Professionalized API.
Der Subscribersound ist zu langsam.
Es ist ein SF-Kamera. Es ist so pro. Du wirst es lieben.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das iPhone 11 Pro die einzige Pro-Kamera für das native App-Ökosystem.
Das App Store hat über 30.000 Fotos und Video-Apps.
Du kannst also alles machen, was du dir vorstellen kannst, direkt auf dem Gerät.
Ein tolles Beispiel ist Filmic.
Sie machen eine tolle App, Filmic Pro, die es möglich macht,
für gewinnwürdige Direktoren zu drücken,
die Boundaries für das, was sie machen.
Das ist möglich mit cinematischem Filmmachen auf dem iPhone.
Wir sind sehr erfreut, ihren CTO Christopher Cohen zu begrüßen.
Und mit ihnen der Direktor der eklatierten Filme The Florida Project und Tangerine,
der erste theatrische Trailer-Fotos auf dem iPhone, Sean Baker.
Willkommen, Leute.
Danke, Phil.
Ich habe Tangerine auf dem iPhone mit Filmic Pro gefilmt.
Ich arbeite seitdem mit Chris und dem Filmic-Team.
Jeder Foto hat den richtigen Weg.
Ich arbeite als Filmmaker, um herauszufinden, welches Foto das ist.
Auf dem Set nutze ich ein Tool, das den Direktoren-Fotografen benötigt.
Es hilft mir, ein Foto zu finden und Fokal-Fotos zu wählen.
Filmmaker haben das seit fast 75 Jahren gemacht.
Aber was, wenn ihr das, was wir alle in unseren Händen haben, benutzen könnt?
Wir freuen uns darauf, das nächste Video von Tangerine auf dem iPhone zu präsentieren.
Wir werden die Filme weiterentwickeln.
Schauen wir uns die nächste Generation der Foto-Fotos an.
Wir haben den Foto-Fotografen geteilt,
und die Filme werden in individuelle Videos veröffentlicht.
Wir visualisieren jedes Bereich der Sicht auf dem neuen iPhone.
Mit dem neuen iPhone A13 und den höheren Warnungen des neuen iPhones,
können wir mit unserer komplexesten Foto-Pipeline filmen.
Aber jetzt könnt ihr mit mehreren Kameras zusammen filmen.
Wenn ihr es noch nicht gemacht habt, macht ein Voting zum Preis.
Und ich liebe das, weil es total transformierend ist.
Mit zwei Kameras, die im Filmic Pro rollen,
bekomme ich zweimal so viel Aufnahme,
wie auf dem gleichen Foto.
Das reduziert die Anzahl meiner Fotos,
und gibt mir mehr Möglichkeiten im Posten.
Um das zu ermöglichen, verwenden wir einen Komponenten-Übergang,
der die primären und zweiten Kameras darstellt.
Während die beiden gleichzeitig gedreht werden,
kann ich mich auf meine A-Kamera konzentrieren,
oder zurück aussehen, um meine größte Sicht zu sehen.
Ich bin immer gespannt, wenn ich Evolution sehe,
und Filmmaking-Style und Kunst.
Und diese Multicam-Feature wird mir neue kreative Möglichkeiten geben,
um Szenen zu öffnen.
So wie ich den traditionellen Shot-Reverse-Shot betrachten würde.
Das stimmt, Sean.
Wir können sogar diese unglaubliche ultra-weite Kamera
mit der vordersehenden Kamera verbinden.
Das ermöglicht mir,
die organische und intime Interaktion
zwischen zwei Individuen
in einem einzigartigen Film
mit einem einzigartigen, unabstrusiven Gerät zu erzeugen.
So kann ich die Publikum
in der Mitte einer Konversation schlagen.
Es ist nicht nur unglaublich für Narrativ-Story,
es wird wunderbar für Dokumentare und Journalisten sein,
von 1.000 bis 2.500 Euro.
Mal gucken, wer am nächsten dran ist.
Ich habe es schon in 500-Euro-Schritten gemacht.
Ob wir richtig liegen.
Thank you, Christopher and Sean.
So, this is iPhone 11 Pro.
In addition to the triple camera system,
A13 Bionic,
longer battery life,
faster charging,
new designs,
there's also faster cellular,
better water resistance,
stronger glass,
and so much more.
We think this is the most exciting iPhone we've made yet.
We've made a video to tell you just a little bit more about it.
Okay, 1.500 Euro liegt vorne zurzeit.
Introducing iPhone 11 Pro.
Every detail has been used as an opportunity
to set new standards in design, quality and engineering,
ensuring it will deliver uncompromising performance in any situation.
At the core of the iPhone 11 Pro design
is a stainless steel structural band
and a three-dimensional glass back,
made from the toughest glass in a smartphone.
Ja, ich habe jetzt Euro.
Tauscht Euro und Dollar aus, ist egal.
Es kostet hier doch eh fast immer das Gleiche.
Plus den Euro-Preis.
Der iPhone 11 Pro wird in einem viertexturierten,
mattem Finanzen.
Oh, der Mauszeiger. Ja, ist gut.
Rigorous testing and refining
have helped create a durable,
dust- and water-resistant iPhone.
So, jetzt abgespritzt.
The Apple-designed A13 Bionic Chip
is the most ambitious to date.
It's the fastest chip ever in a smartphone,
yet more efficient than ever.
And with new optimized batteries
that give you up to five extra hours in your day,
you get more pro performance in an iPhone
for longer than ever.
The triple camera system
combines cutting-edge technology
with the extraordinary ease of iPhone.
The redesigned camera interface
complements the new hardware
with a more immersive and intuitive experience.
Ja, wir haben es ja jetzt verstanden.
Wie oft wollt ihr das noch erzählen?
Das erzählen wir jetzt zu vierten Mal.
... and new ultra-wide cameras.
You can now view four times more seen
in your photos and videos
with the ultra-wide.
All-new Night Mode allows you to capture images
never before possible on an iPhone
in drastically lower light.
The highest quality video in a smartphone
is now even better.
With extended dynamic range
now at 4K at 60fps,
you can record pro-quality video
at twice as many frames per second.
Habt ihr bestimmt noch nie gehört, oder?
Editing tools previously reserved for photos
now make editing your videos
a pro-level experience.
Perfect and then play back your footage
on the new Super Retina XDR display
that has the highest pixel density
of any Apple device.
Privacy is built into every iPhone
from the ground up.
From iOS 13 to Face ID,
the most secure facial authentication
in a smartphone, which now works
from greater angles and is even faster.
This new line of iPhone
has been pushed to extremes
like never before.
Ensuring that each part
is worthy of the name
iPhone 11 Pro.
So iPhone 11 Pro
and iPhone 11
are made to be designed
free from these harmful materials
and of course to reduce their impact
on the environment.
And this is so important to us.
So I bring it up every time.
We want to keep pushing
the boundaries of this.
iPhone 11, iPhone 11 Pro
are our most advanced phones.
Everyone's gonna want to show them off.
And some people like to protect them
with cases. So we have a new line of cases
for them as well, including clear cases
for all three models.
So you can show off your beautiful new finishes.
So iPhone 11 Pro
will start at $999
and iPhone 11 Pro Max
at just $100 more
at $1099.
Das geht doch.
Warum ist Apple so billig in letzter Zeit?
Also, also billig.
Also sagen wir mal.
Also billig ist ja
falsches Wort für...
Ich mein, 1000 Euro für ein Smartphone
ist immer noch total behämmert.
Also Leute, unter 1000 wäre richtig gewesen.
Es hat kaum einer gevotet.
Ich mein, die Kamera sieht schon irgendwie
merkwürdig aus, ne?
Ich mein, das sieht echt beknackt aus
da oben mit der Kamera dran.
Kennt man die?
Thanks so much, Tim.
I would love to start this
update on Apple Retail
by giving a huge shoutout to our retail team members
all around the world.
The customer truly is at the center
of everything that we do.
Der Customer hat ja auch das Geld.
There really is no better place
to see this in action than in our stores.
Today we'd love to share two ways
we're making the experience even better.
Let's start with personalization.
Apple Retail has always been the best
place to help you customize
and personalize your products.
And now we're going to take it even further
with Apple Watch.
Currently, we offer a wide selection
of watches where we choose
and pair the cases with the bands.
With Apple Watch Series 5
we're thrilled to announce
the all new Apple Watch Studio
where you choose and pair
any case with any band
with exactly the watch that you want.
Okay, da muss mal so eine Hardcore Apple Fanboy
sein für.
The Apple Watch Studio Experience
is available in our stores
and online.
And with so many different combinations
there are nearly a thousand different ways
to represent your own personal style.
Now, next,
we'd love to talk about
Apple Trade-In.
Oh, kann ich mein iPhone loswerden?
You just saw all of this great news
about our new iPhones.
Now you can use your current iPhone
as credit towards a new iPhone.
And because we know many of our customers
prefer to pay by month,
we're pleased to offer low monthly payments
in a number of our countries.
Apple Trade-In makes your new iPhone
even more affordable.
And because we reuse and recycle,
it's great for the planet.
And thanks to the services that we offer,
there is so much more, so much.
And the entire store experience
is brought to life by our amazing teams
and the care that they have for our customers.
This deep care,
along with our incredible collection
of products, services,
and experiences like today at Apple,
are designed to delight
and are available only at Apple.
Now finally,
our stores are the best place
for a celebration.
So on September 20th, the same day
as our iPhones and Apple Watches arrive,
we're thrilled to be hosting
our biggest store reopening ever.
Apple Fifth Avenue.
Is this the Kappa Pride Store?
The newly expanded public plaza
is going to be a wonderful place
for the community to gather.
And inside, everything's been
completely transformed.
We've dramatically increased the height
and we've nearly doubled the size,
making it our largest in the world.
Apple Fifth Avenue
has a special place in our hearts
and we can't wait to welcome you back.
That's a quick update on retail.
Back to you Tim.
Thank you.
I am so proud of our retail team
and the unique experience they deliver
to our customers every day.
They are amazing.
And I'm especially thrilled
that the iconic Fifth Avenue store
is reopening.
I hope to see all of you there
on September 20th.
It's an exciting morning.
I hope you guys have had
as much fun as I have.
We shared the all-new Apple Arcade,
a game subscription service
unlike any other,
coming to the App Store this month.
And Apple TV Plus
with powerful and unique
Apple Originals
for today's most creative storytellers
coming to the Apple TV App
beginning November 1st.
And the new iPad
bringing a 10.2-inch
Apple Pencil and Smart Keyboard
and the power of iPadOS
to more people than ever before.
The new Apple Watch Series 5
with its always-on
retina display,
compass,
new finishes
and the amazing new features
of WatchOS 6.
The new iPhone 11
with its new dual camera system,
powerful A13 chip,
beautiful new finishes
and incredible capabilities.
And of course,
the stunning new iPhone 11 Pro
with its jam-packed
with advanced technologies
designed to enable people
to do even more than before.
Our mission at Apple
has always been
to design products
that empower people
and enrich people's lives.
To put technologies in your hands
and to see all the wonderful things
that you'll do with them.
We couldn't be more proud
to share with you this morning.
For those of you
here today with us,
we'd like to invite you
to experience them
first in the hands-on area upstairs.
And I'd like to thank everyone
at Apple
for doing the best work
of their lives
in bringing these products
and services to market.
And I'd like to thank everyone.
Thank you.
And I'd especially like to thank
everyone that came out this morning
and everyone that tuned in online
to watch the keynote this morning.
Thank you and have a great day.
Also, rein von dem,
wie er irgendwie auftritt,
dem kauf ich das irgendwie ab.
Das ist eben auch wirklich was an den Leuten liegt,
die daran beteiligt sind.
Da kriegt er den goldenen Cup of Bright
nochmal für die.
Fertig! Einfach so!
Jetzt kommt er gleich nochmal rausgestürmt
und sagt, haha, hinsetzen, kommt nochmal!
Okay, Leute, also,
was war dabei Tolles?
Achso, ich muss euch mal ein Foto zeigen.
Hat gerade einer über Twitter gepostet hier
oder im Chat.
Hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, oder?
Ich finde, es sieht schon recht ähnlich aus.
Okay, ein Pingo
konnte ich nicht machen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch...
Hat es bei jemand von euch geklappt?
Ich konnte jetzt nicht das Bild minimieren.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ja, es ist 20.43.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Spitze hatten wir 576 Zuschauer.
Das ist neuer Rekord.
Das ist übelst huge.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat,
könnt ihr mal ein Follow dalassen.
Schaut mal vorbei,
auf YouTube und Twitter
bin ich auch am Start.
Eigentlich bin ich hauptsächlich mehr auf YouTube am Start
als auf Twitch.
Meistens
mache ich auf Twitch
irgendwelche Technik-Geschichten.
Ab und zu spielen wir auch mal
irgendwelche
Call of Duty oder sonst was.
Aber hauptsächlich mache ich auf Twitch
Technik-Tempel.
Könnt ihr mal in die letzten paar
Worts reingucken.
Wer jetzt neu ist, dass es ungefähr ein Gefühl dafür kriegt,
was ich mache, ob das was für euch ist.
Wenn das was für euch ist, lasst einfach ein Follow da.
Und...
Dann würde ich sagen,
schön, dass alle dabei waren.
Wir machen Schluss.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Servus.
Bis bald.